a novel way to produce electricity in
punjab
leftover straw from some of the state's
paddy fields is being burnt
to generate power for a 50-acre
industrial area
says he began looking for cheaper and
more environmentally friendly
alternatives to power his factories
when petrol prices peaked in 2013. this
is a
power plant three megawatt power plant
based 100 on the pedi straw
here what we are doing is we are burning
this pedestal in a very controlled
manner
we are generating high pressure stream
and with the high pressure steam we are
generating power
hans raj pays farmers to collect paddy
straw for the factory there's no
shortage of it in the state which is one
of india's biggest rice producers
60 people were employed by baldev singh
over the one month harvest season last
year
when five million kilos of straw was
collected from 500 farmers
before this we used to burn the husk but
since these machines and this
opportunity opened up
we have managed to reduce pollution and
by selling the husk we also make a
profit
as well as converting leftover straw to
cleaner electricity
some are also selling it to companies
which make cardboard out of it
around punjab farmers and others are
finding ways to recycle
crop stubble instead of burning it in
the fields that causes air pollution to
rise to
hazardous levels for hundreds of
kilometers
[Music]
india's government began imposing fines
on farmers for burning stubble in 2015
but removed them last month after
protests farmers say they shouldn't be
penalized when they don't have
alternatives to clear their land in time
for the winter sowing season
the government offers farmers just over
one dollar for every
100 kilos of stubble they collect and
don't burn
but experts say most farmers don't have
the expensive machines needed
to gather the waste so i think that is
the lack of
attention of the government and the
scientific community
to provide a possible solution to use
this waste as a useful
kind of product they have to develop
electricity plants
the second is that they have been they
have to
develop manufacturing plants hans raj
garg says he saved around a million
dollars a year on power since using
paddy's straw to fuel his factories he
also paid baldev singh
27 000 last year for the straw and what
they both say
is a win-win situation for farmers
industries
and the environment elizabeth puranam al
jazeera
amlo punjab